Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my brand new suicide squad trailer video
There's a brand new Suicide Squad movie
that they're releasing next year.
Surprise, surprise. But it's Suicide Squad.
Isekai it's basically a suicide squad anime
that Warner Brothers had debuted studio do.
I've done a couple anime videos on the channel.
I don't do them all the time every single week.
Like there aren't a lot of anime
shows like I did Attack on Titan for a while,
but it's a little bit different
doing videos for anime stuff than it is
for live action
stuff, mostly because of copyright reasons.
Just because copyright rules over in
Japan are vastly, vastly different
than they are everywhere else in the world.
So it makes it way harder
to actually do videos for anime stuff.
but it actually looks pretty solid.
I'll explain what's going on and how this sort of fits
into the grand scheme of James Gunn's
big reboot of DC movies and TV shows
because he's also rebooting all the animated stuff.
So it is going to be canon with the live action stuff,
kind of the way that Marvel is doing things right now.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll probably give away a couple of copies
when this comes out
because I believe it's going straight to DVD.
Like it's not going to be a theatrical release,
but we'll probably find out more about that soon.
most of Warner Brothers
animated DC stuff is all pretty solid.
They have a Justice League crisis
on Infinite Earths movie that's coming out next year.
It's actually a three part movie.
Like Part one is coming out the beginning of the year.
I've already done a trailer video for that.
is basically meant to be a straight up retelling
of the crisis on infinite Earths origin story,
but using the tomorrow verse of characters like that
current continuity of their animated universe.
The past couple of years, I believe that parts
two and parts three of that movie are coming out
later during 2024,
but basically that is a straight to home video release
that's like the Jensen Ackles version of Batman,
the Darren Criss version of Superman, all tomorrow
verse stuff, the stuff that started with Superman,
Man of Tomorrow in the past, I've considered all the DC
animated stuff to be like a completely separate
universe just because you have stuff like Batman,
the animated series, which is amazing obviously,
but it's kind of set off in its own universe.
then you're the traditional
DC animated universe that most of us
think of when we think of the DC animated universe.
They ended that
or they started a reboot of that with Justice
League apocalypse
or that rebooted into the Tomorrow verse.
Now they're doing the same thing,
rebooting into James Gunn's DCU animated stuff.
so essentially this suicide squad E6
is meant to be an elseworlds kind of production.
He talked a little bit about this
in his big announcement video where he talked
about the reboot of everything
live action and animated.
there'll be some elseworlds stuff
happening in the future like Matt Reeves Batman
universe is still considered elseworlds in live action.
if you're not familiar with it studio
the people that actually made this over in Japan
they do a lot of solid work
like they did attack on Titan for a few seasons.
I did do a couple seasons worth of videos
for that right now they're doing Spy X Family,
which is actually a pretty great series.
I watched that in my free time,
but I don't make videos for it.
There are a lot of their series that I watch.
They don't actually make videos
for like Great Pretender on Netflix ranking of Kings.
That was pretty solid.
They did the first season of Vinland Saga,
which is amazing.
I'd also advise watching that
if you haven't seen it yet.
in the actual animation, the characters, the voiceover
performance actually does seem pretty solid,
even though if you're not really familiar
with the Isekai genre or anime just in general,
it does look pretty crazy Right now
in the world of anime,
the Isekai
genre is just so overwhelmingly popular.
If you went to Crunchyroll, for instance,
and you look through all the different shows,
most of them would probably be
some iteration of an Isekai type of trope
there are a lot of differences within the Isekai genre, like different types of tropes,
but typically it involves a character dying
and then reincarnating into another world
with new powers or some crazy stat
boo's in the other worlds that they get reincarnated
to tend to lean towards fantasy tropes
like you go from modern day on your world,
you get reincarnated to a fantasy world with medieval
level technology, but you have magical powers. Now.
it be kind of like getting reincarnated
into like a World of Warcraft type of universe.
in fact characters being reincarnated into video games.
MMO games is actually an EKG genre or subgenre
there've been so many types of Isekai
shows and Isekai manga
that there have been hundreds of different iterations
on that whole formula, just starting.
At the beginning of the trailer for this year.
The main characters.
It seems like during this, the people
that will actually be on Task Force X on the actual
suicide squad are Harley Quinn jokers in the movie,
but it doesn't seem like he's going to be on the team.
Peacemaker, King, Shark, Clayface and Deadshot
and obviously
Amanda Waller running the team
The footage is all over the place.
I just kind of give you some mish
mash of what's going on with the actual plot.
But it seems like Amanda Waller finds or gains access
to some magical or technological portal
that gives them access to the other world,
setting up the whole sky plot.
Or maybe it's a creature in the other universe that
opens up the portal to their world, threatening it.
And that's why she's sending the suicide squad to kill
whoever opened the portal.
But it's basically the suicide squad characters
being put on a fantasy world in another universe.
Like that's what all the orcs are during the trailer,
Harley Quinn talks about them
having 60 hours to complete their mission
before the bombs in their heads explodes in the cage.
Just run off and stay in the other universe forever.
Harley Quinn seems like she tells Joker about it or
he learns about it,
and maybe he also tries to take over the world.
You'd imagine
Batman is somewhere in there chasing him down.
Well, this is all going on, too.
Like he captures them.
And that's how she winds up on this task. Force X.
there's usually the typical formula,
like she's in Gotham City with Joker.
Batman catches them, throws them in prison, Bell red.
And then it's when Amanda Waller picks them up
and puts her on task Force X.
one of the funny things about this too,
like them doing a suicide squad or Harley
Quinn type of anime is that they actually said
when they were making Batman
the animated series way back in the nineties
when the animators were working on it,
they actually said that Bruce Timm told them
that some of their early work on it was too quote
unquote anime like make it less anime,
make it look more like American animation.
I don't know what that would have looked like.
But I think it's just the idea of the way
the animate characters move.
Just some of the anime tropes in general
that you see in those animated series.
Harley Quinn,
though in particular just feels kind of like
she leans towards anime
anyway, like she works as an anime character.
Just as good as she does is regular animation
they start the trailer with Harley Quinn and Joker
looking like they're taking over some tower here
with a bunch of businessmen
all wrapped up with those joker faces on them.
this is probably before she gets captured
and put on the suicide squad.
But she has this voice over from a later in the movie
where she talks about going to the other world.
we get a little bit of the chase in Gotham with Joker's
Card.
This is probably when Batman captures them.
we get a little shot of the portal
in Amanda Waller's base.
This is how they get to the other world.
this might be where the portal actually generates.
The interesting thing, though, is that
in a lot of suicide squad stories, usually the main
villain winds up actually being Amanda Waller, like
she winds up being worse than like the Joker character.
so maybe she was actually doing something,
experimenting with something in.
That's how the portal got opened on her side of things.
that was kind of the idea with James
Gunn's more recent Suicide Squad movie in 2021,
the idea that the American government
was the real main villain
in Amanda Waller was trying to cover up
a bunch of shady stuff they had done, And that's
why she sent the suicide squad to Corto Maltese
to deal with Starro in the Thinker.
The Thinker basically explained
that he was an employee, like a regular, upstanding
employee of the American government.
So really, they were the terrible ones.
end throughout the trailer,
you just see all the suicide squad characters
just having their adventure on the other world.
Not really sure how they're going to wrap this up
though.
Like, obviously
they'll probably come back to the main universe,
they don't really list
when they're actually releasing this.
They just say it's coming in 2024 at some point.
Now I know people are asking what's going to happen
with the suicide squad in James Gunn's new DCU,
because a lot of people assume
because now he's the Kevin Foggy over at DC,
he's is going to bring all of his DCU stuff
into the DCU and make them canon.
He did say that Peacemaker Season two
will be inside the DCU.
So pretty much all the Peacemaker characters
who are Suicide Squad characters will transition over
like they'll still be playing their characters
he didn't really explain
how they're going to explain the whole reboot thing,
because at the end of Peacemaker season one, Peacemaker
literally comes up real close and sees the faces
of some of the Justice League characters.
so this is some point during peacemaker season two,
they have to address the Justice League
looking completely different, like, wait a minute,
that's not Aquaman, That's not the Flash.
What happened?
my whole idea and I've talked about this
in previous videos and I think this would totally work,
just totally be in the tone of the character
is that you have peacemaker Served is sort of like
the psycho pirate in this big reboot crisis on infinite
Earths style within the context of the story cycle,
Pirate was cursed
to remember everything that happened
before the big crisis reboot, so to speak.
So he remembered all these universes.
All of these are the versions of characters that died.
would James Gunn can do in the new DCU?
Live action stuff is just have Peacemaker
be that character, because his whole thing is
that he's just always spouting off
about crazy conspiracy theories.
Nobody ever believes anything that he says
because it's so crazy.
So he can just start Peacemaker Season
two complaining about how the Justice League
is different in everything rebooted
like there's a big reboot in the universe.
How come nobody's talking about it?
but everyone posts all your reactions
to the suicide squad animal.
I'll do more videos when they release more footage
in the next couple of months.
It'll probably come out
sometime in the first half of 2024.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up this week.
My marvel.
What if season two episodes will start soon
I'll try to do some videos for the upcoming movie,
like a post-credits scene video, full breakdown,
Easter eggs, that kind of stuff.
there's also the Zack Snyder Rebel Moon movie.
I'll try to do a couple of videos for that too.
speaking of big DC reboots,
I just did a Henry Cavill Warhammer video
because he's going to be doing a Warhammer series
in Warhammer movies over at Amazon.
Click here to learn about that.
It looks like it's going to be bad
as and click here for that Justice League
crisis on Infinite Earths Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!